está elaborada nacional a la federación
médica del perú realizan pero extendiera
los vientos
fue incrementó el presupuesto para el
sector salud
nivelación de salarios equipo de
protección personal y un bono que
también protestan por la muerte de 143
a causa de coros y alerta que 3.529
están contagiados con el portal button
es una protesta en vista de que el
gobierno no cumple con los compromisos
que tiene en primer lugar en el plan de
gobierno dice claramente que sirven cree
mentar el presupuesto en 0 5% del pp y
por año
han pasado cuatro años y sólo se ha
aumentado el 0 3% del pib y este año se
pretende aumentar el 0 18 en cinco años
ni lo que debía aumentarse en un año los
trabajadores del sistema de seguridad
social también se unieron a la protesta
ellos reclaman mejores condiciones de
vida seguridad en hospitales y centros
de salud así como ascensos y una escala
remunerativa de salarios de russian que
se 30 trabajadores fallecieron y nueve
mil están contagiados con el coi 19
nosotros
seguimos en el tema del diálogo con el
gobierno en sus distintos
estamento pero de no tener de no lograr
de no alcanzar soluciones concretas a
nuestra problemática a nuestra demanda
como acuerdo nacional tenemos como
siguientes pasos la huelga nacional
indefinida las autoridades peruanas
reprochan la protesta de los médicos que
se producen cuando el país tiene más de
600 siete mil contagiados y más de 28
mil fallecidos por el coronavirus
[Música]